foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where that is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
actually love and create real amazing
relationships George Campbell Ramsay
personality host of the fine print
podcast on Ramsey networks is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money if you happen
to be running around uh New York City
for some reason or another and you're in
Times Square look up you'll see us the
fine folks at Amazon music
um don't uh donate it or lent us their
uh digital Billboards all around the
side of one building up there to
advertise the Ramsay show of course
Amazon music carries the podcast of this
show
we appreciate them doing that and so
wherever you listen to podcasts is fine
but got a little Ramsay show digital
action there going on in Times Square
All the Time Square tourists are now
tuning into the show yeah welcome
well I mean it's got my picture on there
so that probably turned I'm afraid that
may mess the whole thing up but it's got
yeah I think it's Rachel and John are
there too yeah me and Ken didn't make
they'll save it for us but yeah anyway
yeah so yeah you work too hard to be
this broke or something like that it
says so yeah check it out guys if you're
running around New York City we
appreciate that and good working with
the fine folks at Amazon music we
appreciate them carrying the podcast uh
this podcast is offered everywhere great
podcasts are offered anywhere you want
to tune in uh it's everywhere so uh
Spotify Amazon
Apple of course
um I don't know wherever else you do
that so I guess Google play right I
heart SiriusXM you name it you got it
all there yeah yeah the Rams we have our
own little Network app that some people
used to tune in YouTube of course
um and I we're on the that's right we
have our own channel on the iHeartRadio
app I forgot about that that's uh that's
been there since I mean there's so many
places you get you're bound to forget a
few at this point well I'm yeah I'm lost
but um yeah on top of the 600 something
stations well that's what my that's
where I started so all this other stuff
has come along since then there's kids
in their newfangled technology get off
my line get off my digital lawn shut up
shut up George open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're gonna start this hour off with
Knoxville Sam is calling hey Sam how are
you
hey good afternoon I'm doing well how
are you doing better than we deserve sir
what's up
okay so uh just to run down I'm married
happily married with three children uh
my wife and I
um have been married for 14 years
something like that now and um we've got
some debt that we want to get paid off
we we have some some big goals in the
future
um and so I just I'm a small business
owner and I really needed advice based
upon that aspect because I think I get
everything else if I have a standard
salary or income like that but with the
idea of being a small business owner I'm
a little bit uh I guess I'm ill-equipped
or you know just ignorant of how to
handle the situation but I'll give you
some numbers I've we've got a truck loan
which is my work truck and it's nineteen
thousand dollars uh we have a mortgage
of 180 000 and then we have eight
hundred dollars and uh just uh two two
different uh zero interest uh credit
cards that are going to be paid off
within the next two months and um so I'm
looking at a little over two hundred
thousand dollars in debt and I I want to
get this knocked out for my family uh so
that I can make sure that we are in a
position where we can help others uh as
well as ourselves and then uh but I
don't want to pay taxes on last year in
your business what's your taxable income
um
uh
54. okay does your wife work outside the
home
she's a full-time household engineer
okay do you anticipate making more than
54 on the business this year yeah I'm
looking to be around 60 to 70. good what
do you do
uh I'm uh I own a carpentry company we
do finish carpentry how many employees
it's just me and then I sub contract out
to two other guys on occasion okay all
right good for you okay
um so it sounds like the income is
fairly predictable
uh and you know if you're doing so if
you're doing trim carpentry there's a
lot of construction in Knoxville so you
shouldn't have any trouble getting work
for the next while without any trouble I
mean you're not going to like dry up and
get zero so you're gonna be fine and you
should be increasing uh pretty steadily
as a matter of fact so uh good news
there as far as running the business
goes what we teach folks in entree
leadership is to hold enough in the
business to make sure the business stays
healthy now what do you actually spend
money on in this business you're a
one-man show you do trim carpentry do
you buy them supplies and then uh in job
ticket the whole thing out or does you
just Supply the labor
so I I do I do some supplies and then I
do the labor and then uh my biggest
expense because I just started last year
was acquiring all of my equipment
um which we were able to do
predominantly through a cash flow but
some of it was uh done through
um uh
temporary debt that lasted you know a
couple months at a time before it was
paid off uh to buy equipment that was
just absolutely needed for that moment
um but I don't I generally keep a
balance on my on my box store card but
it's nothing that doesn't get knocked
down every every month I I chop away I
don't always have a zero balance there
though as I try and you know figure out
how to do capital and all that and do I
need to push what you need to do is you
need to stop that because that's a
that's a rubber crutch it's going to
fall under you okay right
um and yeah the other thing is you'll
end up buying crap uh in the name of I
need another Tool uh that you really
didn't have to have and and right so
what what I want you to do is I want you
to pay cash for or write a check or
debit card for your equipment purchases
and I want you to hold back a percentage
of your profits before you take money
home
now you're you're setting money aside
for taxes every month right
um yes and yes yes we are yeah we
thought it wasn't very convincing
yeah so we we did last year and we
actually ended up not paying taxes last
year because of the amount of income so
we've got money set aside as a part of
our just we just have one savings
account and how did you not pay income
with a fifty four thousand dollar income
um so okay so I think I misunderstood
your question then so after taxes no I
was not at 54. I was down
at 42.
I'm sorry not not after taxes after I
was asking what your profit was that you
paid taxes on if you had a taxable
income of fifty four thousand dollars
you did pay taxes
yeah yeah you're right I'm sorry I think
I think I just I think I misspoke sorry
apologies that's okay so you need to be
setting aside money for your taxes each
month out of your profits before you
take money home and you need to set
aside a small amount for a tool fund
each month before you take money home
and then take everything else home and
then George work the baby steps yeah
this is just going to go in the debt
snowball so let's pay off the credit
cards get rid of the truck loan switch
to a business debit card and start using
cash to run this whole thing and that's
going to keep you from getting into the
cycle where you're trying to keep up
yeah you're you're gonna get caught in a
cycle because we work with construction
people and have for 20 years in entree
leadership and uh I've kind of got that
in my DNA as well I grew up in the real
estate business dad Built Homes when I
was a kid and so I love tools I buy
tools I don't even know what they do but
I need the tool you know and so that
those of us that are cut out of that
cloth we tend to overspend on tools that
we in air quotes have to have and I want
you to have the minimum tool purchase
because it's overhead to get the job
done this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today guys we really value input
from you that watch and listen to the
show it helps us to know what's
important to you so we can deliver the
right content that will help you with
the questions and the challenges that
you have we want to give you uh
motivation inspiration and information
so you change your life that's our idea
one way you can share your thoughts with
us is by answering a few questions in a
new survey we just launched
you can check out the ram check it out
at ramsesolutions.com survey takes just
a few minutes and uh we will do a
drawing among the people that take the
survey someone will win randomly a 500
Visa gift card check it out
ramseysolutions.com survey we want to
hear from you so it's one of those
surveys we found out how popular Georgia
is is that true it is true I'm hearing
it for the first time yes it's actually
came back your your rate your personal
ratings are very good on the show that's
good to hear so all right that is job
security folks so thank you for all
those nice people out there do they get
to rate you too
um yeah but the difference is I don't
care
yo um I care deeply I need all the
validation and affirmation I can get
I've been doing it 30 years I'm probably
just get off my lawn guys you're done
taking a poll I'm just I mean I want a
beacon I want to be helpful I want to be
attuned to the customer need but we're
not taking a poll on this is not like
the YouTube comment section we actually
want to make the show better so we want
good critical thinking skills here folks
sorry just busted on the YouTube crazy
too soon wow all right Jack is in
Richmond Virginia hey Jack how are you
hey guys I'm doing great how are you
better than I deserve how can I help all
right so today my wife and I just
finished up baby step two this morning
we just made our last our last dead
payments
how much did you pay off in the world
uh we paid off ninety seven thousand
dollars in 11 months whoa kicking it so
we've been we've been hustling
um and the last the last thing you know
my question is is we have about 70 000
sitting in a traditional IRA
um I'm 29 she's 27. and my question is
as a part of we're finishing up uh going
on to baby step three here should we
convert that to raw and pay the taxes on
it
um as a part of just just finishing up
80 step two no I'm at our age with that
dollar amount no after after baby step
seven you would
okay okay I don't want you to pay tax
bills while you still got a mortgage
that makes sense
that makes sense yeah you know I always
hear you guys say the you know match
beats Rossi's traditional it does so all
your stuff going forward should follow
that formula but this one I don't want
to convert it because converting it is
going to create a you know a fifteen
thousand dollar or so tax bill
yes exactly that's what I was worried
about it was another 15 000 that I that
I wasn't looking forward to paying off
um but I didn't know if it would be the
smart thing to do or not so it is once
you've got extra money we got priorities
here so we got to get the fully funded
emergency fund begin investing 15
percent get the down payment get the
house paid off and then we have all the
margin in the world because we don't
have payments and you can do stuff like
that
John is in Oklahoma City hey John
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey thanks Dave how are you guys better
than we deserve sir what's up okay
awesome well I took uh the Dave Ramsey
advice here sold my duplex and uh you
know take the proceeds from that and uh
I was planning on paying off my my truck
but uh
I when I bought my house my primary
house in April I had a co-signer because
I didn't have enough uh
job history I just started a couple
months ago and uh I know it probably
wasn't the smartest thing but uh anyways
really what I'm getting at here is uh I
think I'd rather pay off the house and I
know it's a larger debt than the truck
just because I'd like to get this
cosigner off without having to refinance
okay so you got enough cash from the
duplex to pay off your home
yeah yeah but not both
but not both right I put a pretty big
down payment on the house and uh so what
do you owe on your house
uh 103 104 something how much you've
gotten proceeds from the duplex
uh 105. okay and you have any other
money
uh yeah I got my savings I got about 30
yeah okay what are y'all on your truck
now about 20. okay
um
what do you make here
uh
this year it's going to be a little bit
lower probably around 45 to 50. uh I'm
just getting ramped up in this whole
thing yeah you're single industry uh yep
single getting married next year oh good
for you okay
uh I'd pay off both
pay off both okay
not much savings but and I want you to
dive in then build your build your
emergency fund up to three to six months
of expenses but I love the idea of
having not a payment in the world that
feels really clean to me
right right yeah I can understand that
I'll have about uh probably around seven
to eight thousand in taxes
um on this on the on the proceeds there
so yeah
but okay yeah I mean I think you can I
still think you can make both of them
what's the truck worth
uh it's worth about 40 38 40. um
it's a lot you're gonna be driving a
forty thousand dollar truck when you
make forty five thousand dollars a year
oh no I don't know yeah I I changed my
mind I would just sell the truck
and sell it okay yeah that ain't
happening but that is what you should do
I went over yeah
immediately and we went from advice to
meddling
either way you're dead free and now
you're in the market for a new less
expensive truck yeah you really
shouldn't be driving a 40 000 truck when
you make forty five thousand dollars a
year because they go down in value
Like a Rock that's where Chevy gets that
like a rock and so yeah you don't you
don't want to do that dude that's bad
investment bad place to have that much
money parked when with that level of
income A good rule of thumb folks is not
have more than half your annual income
tied up in things with wheels and motors
things with wheels and Motors go down in
value and so when you got over you make
80 000 you got sixty thousand dollars
worth of freaking toys
you it's really diff you know you are
you are like saying I am middle class
and plan to stay that way that's what
you're saying right and so uh looking
good in the at the stoplight and that's
it not in the balance sheet and so
um you know wealthy people think
differently about this and that's how
they became wealthy and uh when you sell
for 40 and you owe 20 he can still go
get him a twenty thousand dollar truck
that makes sense
yeah that would be about half of his
annual income and you know and George I
know trucks have gone up but twenty
thousand dollar truck is not a bad truck
now you can get and people it's not a
forty thousand dollar trip it doesn't
have a lot of features I want not a bad
truck well I mean you know you know
truck guys you're one of them I yeah I
just drove my raptor in here this
morning tried to park it between those
little electric thing hey you chose that
parking spot Dave I well no they put the
little plug-in stupid thing right beside
my parking spot which is kind of like
insulting to the Raptor it just it's
true it has it gets the hives every time
I pull up next to one of those little
plug-ins I apologize me and Rachel
apologize to your Raptor next time we
pull up next to it your little plug-in
car owes an apology I'm just saying
truck but hey truck people are their own
breed day people get on to me they go
with George you don't understand you're
not a truck guy that's right I need this
to 65 000 truck well you know
everybody's got a thing where they say
I'm that guy but let me just tell you
what you are you're a broke guy when you
put too much in stuff that goes down in
value you can blame it on the battery
you can blame it on the truck you can
blame it on I um you know I any shiny
object I had to get I had to get a new
bass boat those with a bigger engine
those bass were out running me I mean so
I mean you can you can figure out a way
to justify anything and call your I'm a
boat guy I'm uh uh what I know you're
not you're you can more Bass with a
better boat is that how it works just
broke that's all and so you know and
I've been that guy so you know the thing
is yeah all of you out there where you
just got it's drive like no one else so
later you can drive like no one else I
mean I drove a piece of crap
that you know it's made of predominant
color on this car was Bondo
and um I mean it wouldn't bring I wasn't
even a 500 car wow
and go forward but that was about the
extent of it and I drove that car for 10
years one three month period
um during that three months I saved
everything I could get and I upgraded
considerably to a 1500 car
and now one hour drive if I got anything
I want anything he wants because I saved
my money and I got out of debt just give
me your worst car work the stuff which
is your worst least favorite car ever I
want to know which one of the ones you
own right now oh that I own right now I
don't have a car that I don't like I get
rid of them if I don't like that's why
they call it a Dave car this is
rebranding it that's it this is the
Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thanks for joining us America this is
the Ramsey show George Campbell Ramsey
personality is my co-host today Joshua's
in Seattle hi Joshua welcome to the show
hey there how y'all doing better than we
deserve sir what's up
so I am a 30 year old single dad
um just got divorced earlier this year
and I'm in about 38 000 worth of debt of
my own
um I feel like I'm living paycheck to
paycheck and I don't know where to start
to just get out of this
um I've reached an emotional point where
I'm done I've had enough
um I know I need to set up a budget but
I'm not sure how or anything like that
or what the first step would be
I'm so sorry about your situation Joshua
how long ago was the divorce when was it
finalized
um it was finalized in January okay
and coming out of this what kind of debt
is that thirty eight thousand
um so it is
personal loans I took out a while ago
and credit card debt okay
what's your income
uh 65 000. okay what do you do for work
I'm a plumber cool
how old are the kids
six and three your full-time custody
I have 50 custody
okay
well we can definitely help you and
we'll give you some resources as well to
uh with this process number one getting
on a budget you're right that is the key
and it's a difficult thing to do and
part of this you might need to deal with
the kind of the trauma and the emotional
side to just get you know you got the
wind knocked out of you and so part of
it is just getting back up and going how
am I going to move forward with this new
life and what does this look like uh and
once we do that then we can focus on the
finances but it feels like you're just
treading water are you able to cover
your bills every month put food on the
table
I'm able to cover my bills every month
um I can somewhat put food on the table
I've Got Friends and an adopted family
around that they help me out quite a bit
with making sure that I'm fed
and the kids are fed
that's good that's what we want you to
cover first everything else can wait and
if that means talking to the creditors
the credit card companies the lenders
and saying hey here's my situation
here's what I can do right now that's
okay how much do you owe in your car
um I own my car outright good how much
is your rent
um so I actually have a mortgage and it
comes out to 2 000 a month
and your take-home pay is what
so my take-home pay is right around 4
500 a month but then I also get
um disability from the Navy and that
comes out to 1500 a month
okay so you're bringing home six
thousand
yeah right right at it
your house payment's awful High Bud uh
it's 33 percent of your time you can't
pay and um yeah that's left over from
the divorce yeah that wasn't what you
signed up for that's left over from the
divorce but that's part of what's
tanking your monthly budget so yeah
getting on a written plan will make you
feel like you've gotten a raise getting
on the budget and uh right so that's
going to be very important but if we
take your six thousand dollars put at
the top of the page and uh we take food
out first and we take lights and water
out second and we take house payment out
third your truck is paid for so you just
got to put gas and insurance on it
that's it and um you know you've got
some money here you shouldn't be like
begging food off of friends
you're just disorganized you're just
disorganized and have the crap beat out
of you because it's been a hard year but
you've got mathematically you're okay
you can you can work through this
um obviously you need to cut up the
credit cards and stop the borrowing you
can't you can't dig it you know you
can't dig your way out of a hole you
gotta you know you can't just keep get
out of a hole while you're digging out
the bottom you can't just keep digging
so no more debt chop them up get on a
written plan and take care of food first
lights and water second house third then
you've got money left out of that
I mean there's two three thousand bucks
laying there to do some stuff with and
we can begin to work on this and then
the other thing too is on the days you
don't have the kids I'd pick up extra
time
as a plumber you can make some serious
money in overtime or side jobs one of
the two
right and you know an extra thousand
bucks a month on this debt makes it go
away a lot faster
okay yep that's a short-term fix but
it's a short-term problem if we get
after it so do you have any cash right
now anything in savings
I got about a hundred dollars
um so step one we've got to get a buffer
between you and life and that's going to
be a starter emergency fund of a
thousand dollars and we're gonna do get
that as quickly as possible we're
talking a few weeks here then we're
gonna move on to the dead snowball uh
which is where we pay off all the debts
smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate and we're going to walk
you through this in Financial Peace
University that's going to be our gift
to you nine videos in there also with
that every dollar that'll help you
create this budget income minus expenses
should equal zero a zero base budget
every dollar should have a job and
you're gonna get to work and over the
next 18 to 24 months you're gonna bust
it to get to a place where these kids
see your sacrifice and you can put food
on the table without having to worry
about anyone else yeah less than one
month I want a thousand dollars less
than a month later I went to these
credit cards gone
and so you're going to list them
smallest largest You're Gonna Knock off
the little ones first and get some
momentum like George's talking about
hang on we'll get you signed up also get
you signed up for Financial Peace
University we'll get you into the class
where you're learning how to handle
money and this all goes in your rear
view mirror then and um this is the year
of life change for you so uh some of it
bad some of it good and we're here to
walk with you so hang on Austin will
pick up Joseph is with us Joseph is in
Salt Lake City hi Joseph how are you
I'm doing pretty good how about yourself
better than I deserve how can we help
um so I'm 21 years old I just came back
from a summer of selling pest control
and I and I made a hundred and seventeen
thousand dollars I I don't have I pay
for myself to go to college I don't have
any car debts I don't have any mortgage
or anything like that and uh I was just
wondering what your best uh advice would
be going forward I I read Dave Ramsey
going growing up my parents have been
helping me through it and I've got an
emergency fund set aside for 10 grand
and I mean I could start
um going into Investments like Roth IRAs
or I don't know they're trying to
um like save for a car a house you know
save for a house so I can just buy it
after college what would you recommend I
I do at this point in my life
foreign
so is this your long-term plan do you
want to stay in Pest Control do you
enjoy it
um I mean I'll probably do it for the
next five years but you said you're
going to college
yeah I'm going to college right now I
currently go every uh fall and winter
it's 10K total for that and I pay for
myself to go to college during the
summer time I go sell pest control so
I'll probably do that for five years
until I graduate and then I'll just get
some kind of job I'll probably go into
business management degree or something
like that you know what are you studying
in college
I'm studying business management
currently okay so do you want to be an
entrepreneur and run your own business
yeah that was always the dream to do but
um you know just life beats you down
sometimes so going to college right now
because I know that's a very good thing
to do at my age and I can always have
that as a fallback but yeah definitely I
will go ahead and finish that degree as
fast as possible and you've got how much
did you have saved out of this hundred
grand
so I have a 117 Grand is what I came
back with okay
um after taxes it'll probably be about
88 grand
um gonna pay my tithing on that got my
emergency fund in the two semesters and
and I bought a car in cash because you
know I needed a car okay
our stuff what did you buy how much you
spend on the car
it was nine grand I got a 2007 Ford
Mustang per PT so I love it very good we
did all right so yeah uh All I'm gonna
do is what cash is left after all the
different things you listed out there
I'm just gonna stack cash it's College
insurance plan
it's ensuring that you go through
college after that it's ensuring that
you go through college you don't need to
start Roth IRAs you don't need to start
a house fund you need to go through
college
debt free
and you've you got this lined up so you
pay your taxes you pay your tithes you
uh pay for the car you set your
emergency fund aside and then you stack
cash and if you graduate from college
with 50 or 60 Grand in that account then
we can talk about starting to invest in
or buying a home then just take it easy
man you're just to go you're so far
ahead of the game you're a go-getter man
you're a hustler that's good that's on
grind man you're doing great big piles
of cash get through school then start
your investing in house buying that's
what I would do this is a Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Danny is with us Danny is in Boca Raton
hi Ben Danny how are you
I'm doing all right how are you better
than I deserve sir how can we help
so I have a three-year-old and a six
week old
um me and my wife would like to put some
money away for them
um we were wondering what the best thing
would be
okay are you uh well we teach folks a
thing called the process for becoming
wealthy and taking care of all the
different components of our life called
the baby steps uh you may have heard of
that you may not but the first thing you
would do is not put money aside for your
kid the first thing you would do is to
set money in an emergency fund of one
thousand dollars a beginner emergency
fund the second thing is get out of debt
everything but the house how much debt
do you guys have
um
pretty much none we only have two credit
cards but they're there's no debt on
them
um we have about three thousand dollars
in emergency fund
okay no car debt no student loan debt
no good what's your household income
um together is about 80 85 90. cool well
once you've done baby step two which is
debt free but the house all that means
is you need to place some scissors
across those credit cards and cut them
up start using debit cards so you don't
accidentally slip into debt which people
do all the time then we would go on to
baby step three which is finish the
emergency fund and you're short on that
you got a three thousand dollar now
account and it needs to be three to six
months of expenses once you have that
then you would begin investing in your
retirement fifteen percent of your
income going away for retirement and
once you got that started then you start
saving for the kids college which is
what you're calling about and uh but the
best thing you can do to stabilize
the the family for the kids is to uh you
know to be to be out of debt and be
building your Investments and then in
addition to that we can start saving for
kids college if you click on smartvestor
at ramseysolutions.com you might find
um a smartvester pro that you will find
a smartvester pro that we recommend sit
down with one that you like that has the
heart of a teacher and you'll want to
learn about 529s and esas and putting
money in mutual funds for your kids
future is that what we're talking about
here
yes sir
okay it says on my screen something
about an iul
yeah we were looking into those because
um but you've got a friend in the
insurance business
yeah yeah
guess what which by the way
yeah so iuls are awful
it's an indexed universal life you never
do investing inside of an insurance
policy it is the world's worst place to
do investing the only people in all of
the financial world that recommend that
you invest inside of a life insurance
policy are insurance people nobody else
does
nobody else believes that crap it's so
outdated so outmoded it's covered in
fees horrible product don't do it was I
unclear
no sir okay and by the way your kids
don't need life insurance life insurance
is meant to replace your income in case
something happens to you so you your
wife you both need a good term life
policy meaning it's not for your whole
life we're talking about a 15 20 year
level term life policy 10 to 12 times
your income if you have those in place
you can rest easy at night yeah and then
if something happens the two of you your
kids will be taken care of right
um right but the uh and you get that at
xanderinsurance.com they'll shop a
gazillion companies get you the best
deal that's who you deal with so and
it's way more affordable than these iul
policies it'll be uh five percent
five dollars if your iul's 100 bucks
this would be five bucks it's literally
five percent it's horrible man so that
just stay away from that so you know
walk your way up into investing in real
Investments and in the meantime make
sure you've got term life insurance in
place and you've got the whole thing
taken care of
Dave I'm seeing this all over social
media I don't know why but the young
people are gravitating towards these
Universal Life policies and here's how
it's marketed they go you know it you're
supposed to use your life insurance
while you're alive did you know that and
everyone's like oh my gosh this is
brilliant this investing policy inside
of my whole life oh my gosh this is
amazing when I become a millionaire and
the commissions and fees these guys are
making selling this crap is insane yeah
and the amount of time you have to spend
pulling that premium every single month
in order to make any amount of money is
absurd well I don't know how it's legal
the indexed universal policy is
um it's a newer version of an old bad
idea is what it amounts to and so what
you're going to find if you take this
product apart and look at the components
of it the insurance portion goes up
every year it's basically what we call
an art an annual renewable term
term insurance all life insurance gets
more expensive every year that you're
alive
period because you're statistically more
likely to die every year you're alive
right brilliant so if you're 51 you're
more likely to die statistically than a
for 50. period okay end of story now why
would you get how do you get then a 15
or a 20-year level term insurance well
it is cheaper than the average of the
15-year of increases so the art would
start out cheaper and it would end
higher and the lines would cross right
in the middle hypothetically if it was
exactly how you see what I'm saying so
the art would go it'd go straight up and
the 15-year would be level and it would
cross right in the middle at seven and a
half years however it doesn't do that
because it is cheaper for an insurance
company to produce a 15-year policy that
because they keep you for 15 years then
it's called persistence in the insurance
business than it is for them to try to
get you to stay with a policy that goes
up every year can you imagine that if
you get a bill and every year it goes up
you're probably more likely to cancel
that so that policy didn't to stay on
the books so it's more expensive for
them to sell Arts so net result is a
15-year is way cheaper than the average
of 15 years of art okay now the index
Universal goes up every year inside the
policy but you don't see it
so if you got a 400 premium a certain
portion like on your you know if you
ever look at your mortgage your mortgage
payment a portion goes to interest a
portion goes to principal the further
you go along more goes to principle less
goes to interest this is exactly the
opposite the further you go along more
goes to Insurance less goes because the
hour to Art is going up every year
inside there less is going to your
Investments and so if you keep the
stupid thing long enough it will begin
to be the point that the premium you're
paying will not even cover the insurance
cost and so it starts to eat back into
your savings just to keep the policy
alive
and the thing gets what we call upside
down in the insurance business and so
now you've got a real piece of crap
that's that's eating itself from the
inside out but they pitch it as this
really sophisticated Nuance listen it's
so complicated you don't understand just
trust me yeah as your insurance guy I'm
gonna make you lots of money let me give
you a clue okay when you drive past most
cities the skyline has Banks
and life insurance companies
these are the two towers in every
Skyline
Santa Claus didn't build those
and those people didn't build them with
wealth they inherited they built them
with money they took from you
Banks screwing you
life insurance companies screwing you
this has been going on for decades
nothing new it's not a new it's not a
new song not a new dance and just
because you put it on Tick Tock for
God's sakes doesn't make it smart as a
matter of fact that kind of dumbs it
down that's a trigger word for you I'm
sorry I shouldn't have mentioned
anything I mean it's just like what we
teach is that you should take the
difference if you pay a five bucks for
term life versus 100 for whole life take
the 95 bucks you would have spent and
invest that and you're going to be way
better off than having touched one of
these crappy policies yeah oh here by
the way after you paid extra on this all
these years and you die
they only pay the face value
they'll pay the face value plus your
savings that you've been paying extra to
bill so it's like a savings account with
a crummy rate of return
that when you die they keep your money
I mean what who would bank with that oh
people that buy stuff on Tick Tock I
think Danny needs better friends yeah
well it's time I mean that happens to
everybody because that's how most
particularly whole life permanent life
crappy life insurance are sold is some
old friend from college suddenly
remembers you my buddy from Northwestern
Mutual said yeah I forgot let's be done
with that oh that's a problem that
happened to me that happened to me I
bought it we've all been when I was a
child boy yep sure did I did the same
stupid stuff and I have a degree in
financing and I fell for them now he's a
grown man America
he made it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the Ramsay show and
we'd love your feedback
to win a 500 Visa gift card no purchase
necessary take the survey at
ramsesolutions.com survey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting for
the PODS moving and storage Studio it's
the Ramsay show where that is dumb cash
is king and the paid off Home Mortgage
has taken the place of the BMW as the
status symbol of choice we help people
build wealth through work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
open phones here today at triple eight
eight two five five two two five George
Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host akosia is on the line in Orlando
hey how are you
hi Mr Anthony how are you better than I
deserve what's up
thank you for all you do God bless you
you too so I have a question about my
mom her landlord is planning on
increasing their rents by 400 and she
has no way to pay this for the next year
she currently makes about 2400 a month
so with the new rents plus utilities and
her um personal bills he's looking at
over 3 000 a month
um as her daughter I've tried to look
for many different places for her to
move to somewhere um cheaper so she can
save money and
um buy a house for next year but she
keeps tossing them aside because she's
very picky anything that's not in her
taste she would just disregard it so how
do I convince my mom that she needs to
find somewhere cheaper so she can save
money she's 54 and she doesn't even have
a single Dollar in retirement savings
she has nothing
but she wants all the bells and whistles
how old are you
I'm 26 years old
okay why does our 54 year old woman
need help picking out her new place
because she she just needs help with
those things she's not too tech savvy
like going on websites and finding new
places you don't have to be tech savvy
to know you can't live there anymore
two pencil
yeah
she's she's not Finance minded at all
I'm the person who's always on has to
pay your bills on time avoid late fees I
always give her business ideas but she
just tosses them aside she doesn't see
the urgency in um fixing her finances
uh she'll get urgency if you don't fix
them for her they'll evict her butt
what's her plan currently the thing is
that just to go into debt 600 bucks a
month
she said she going to get a second job
but here's the thing my mom is a single
mother she's always worked two or three
jobs so it's taken a huge toll in her
health over the years so I really don't
want her getting a second job and I want
her to buy a house and save money for
retirement but she doesn't understand
that she needs to find somewhere cheaper
and save money
I agree with your conclusion I agree
with your conclusions
and I appreciate you loving your mom and
wanting good things for her
I am really confused why you're the only
adult in this conversation
with your mom
um this is not your job
she's 54 freaking years old it's time
that she learned how to do something
you know yes I mean I don't my kids
don't run around taking care of Dave
yeah and I don't even run around taking
care of them they're like your age
so I mean these are supposed to be like
adult activities you shouldn't be having
to caretake your mom unless she has some
kind of mental disability and then
you're taking care of her I understand
that but she doesn't have a mental
disability she just doesn't give a crap
yeah it doesn't sound like he has a lot
of Drive either what's she doing for
work exactly she's a CNA that's all
she's done for many years full time
um she works three days and then four
days
yeah okay so what would I do if I were
in your shoes
now that I'm getting over just being
aggravated at your mother for being
irresponsible okay
um I I appreciate the the journey that
you are on and the question that you're
asking but I the answer is I don't think
you can
do this for her and I don't think you
should do this for her it's not good for
you it's emotionally weird
it's a boundary violation and it's not
good for her
so instead what I would do is step to
the side and have a conversation with
her that sounds like this
mom
I love you
and I want you to have a great life you
have worked so hard for so many years
that it makes me cry that you are
struggling
I can't do this for you
I won't do this for you
but I will be your biggest cheerleader
and I'll even coach you on some things I
think you should do but you're going to
have to ask me what you think what I
think you should do I'm not going to
tell you anymore
and if she decides to sit over there and
do nothing and get evicted that is her
grown-up decision it is not your
responsibility you need to wash your
hands of this
it is not in your you can't fix her life
she has to fix her life and even if you
could you shouldn't
it's weird and toxic
so your love for her and your uh honor
for her for all the wonderful hard work
she's poured in and your wish for her
that that she has good things is
dependent not on you it's dependent on
her
to go to get those things you can't do
it for her nor can you just nor do I
have a sentence that you can say to her
that says now all of a sudden this lady
who's never had any ambition gets some
this lady who's chosen not to ever deal
with finances at all suddenly wants to
go do that now but what you can do is
come alongside her and just say Mom I
love you I'll help you any way I can in
terms of coaching you and I'll be your
biggest cheerleader but I'm not going to
do it for you and I'm not going to carry
the emotional burden of you not being
able to pay your rent when you refuse to
carry the OWN your own emotional burden
of you not being able to pay your rent
does that sound harsh to you
no it sounds it sounds reasonable
perfect
she's not gonna die from getting evicted
but she she's had
she's not scarce because
fix it honey
okay she has to fix it
you're more worried about her than she
is
she's not worried about it
is she yeah
I mean on a scale of one to ten you're a
nine on worrying about her on a scale of
one to ten she's a two on worrying about
her am I right
now so I mean you cannot you know uh
if my kid doesn't want me to eat pizza
and fried bologna anymore toughies I'm
still gonna eat it I'm 62. I'm free I
get to make these choices and if my 30
year old doesn't like it tuffies
I'm still eating fried bologna and I'm
still gonna eat pizza
and biscuits and stuff okay and Dad I'm
worried about your health I understand
but I'm not worried about as much as you
are I'm still going to eat that these
are choices that grown-ups get to make
all change starts with being angry about
your situation until she hits that point
she's not gonna change and enabling her
is not going to help her long term but
you can put your arm around her and say
I'm worried about you and when you're
ready to do this stuff I'll be your
biggest cheerleader
and I'll be your biggest coach
but I can't coach a wet blanket so you
mom when you get ready to move I'll help
you
but I can't do it for you
[Music]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America this is the
Ramsey show Tom is with us Tom's in Salt
Lake City how are you Tom
I'm doing great how are you better than
I deserve what's up
at the end of the baby steps we're we're
debt free thankfully in large part to uh
to you and your program and and uh just
some crazy life experiences that enabled
us to get there we've worked real hard
and that's where we're at now
um so we are both now looking into our
retirement uh and but both of us started
this whole journey and in our 30s and so
our and our retirement Investments were
rather and kind of pretty delayed we
were we didn't start investing until
like I said our early 30s and so what we
have now is uh we started with a very
modest income uh Al uh my wife works and
and I own my own business so we have a a
a much larger income than we had before
so what's your household income now
right now we're close to 400. wow look
at you how old are you again
I'm 39. oh wow amazing you're ancient I
can't believe you're getting around and
um I know yeah and uh and how much do
you have in retirement
uh as we saw after this year we'll have
about uh about a hundred good for you
good okay and uh how much debt do you
have
we are debt free it's taken us eight
years house and everything everything's
gone everything's gone house and
everything
yep way to go dude way to go what's the
house worth
I personally think it's worth probably
about 400 or so but the market says that
it's about 6.50 so well I mean the
market is it gets to the side you don't
get to decide so I'm calling it 650 then
good for you man well done well done and
you're making a bank what a great
business you do at this is awesome so
now all you got to do you're what we
call baby step seven so now you're all
you gotta do is stack up cash now dude
and with a 400 000 shovel you ought to
be able to stack it up pretty fast
that's what we're we're really excited
about and we're looking at potentially
retiring
um in the next 10 years yeah for sure so
what's your question today um sounds
like you're doing great my question
today yeah well my question really is
um as far as the 15 of your income into
retirement that doesn't apply to you
you're a baby step seven that's only
when you're on baby step four you can
ramp that up once you get to the house
page that's what I needed to hear yeah
baby step seven is save as much as you
can give as much as you can live as much
as you can in your plan oh that sounds
so great for to hear you say that if we
if we dump in you know 100 to 150 a year
into this into this uh investment firm
that um that we found through your smart
investor Pros um they're helping us out
because I am very investment on savvy so
they're they're guidance through that
yeah
um if we just dump in 150 a year then
we're their forecast says that within 10
years we could
um retire as multi-millionaires and live
off oh yeah you probably have a couple
million in that alone and the house will
be worth a couple million then
so yeah I mean you're going to be 400 4
million dollar net worth at 50 years old
is what it sounds like to me
oh ah it's good you see that yeah I mean
if you if you keep making this kind of
bank and you drop 150 in there I mean
150 for 10 years is a million and a half
plus the growth during that time is
easily another half million probably
another million actually
150 is 1.5 million dude okay 39 to 49.
so that's something that's exactly what
we're looking at yeah you don't have to
have like a calculator or anything to do
that you can do that one in your head so
then then you just add some you know the
growth that you're going to make on top
of that during that time is astronomical
and so
yeah there's another million easy on
there
growth and growth yeah
just uh she'll double every about seven
years or so you're gonna be in great
shape just work with your smart Mr Pro
keep laying out a plan shovel the cash
over there and uh here's the trick is to
avoid getting arrogant in the middle of
this
and blowing it up before you get there
that's the trick because what happens is
you look over there and you got a
million dollar paid for house and you
got a couple million dollars a million
dollars laying in mutual funds in your
retirement and then you go I can afford
to go do this stupid thing now and
people can you can blow the whole thing
up by derailing Just Dance with a girl
that brought you stick with the program
the you know dance with the one that
brought you to the ball just stick with
the program don't get over here and go
oh no now I'm going to bitcoin is now my
answer I put it all in nodes you know
people they get you get a little bit of
hubris and suddenly your brain just
fries out so just don't do that just
mutual funds and paid for Real Estate
just keep it simple and stack cash and
you're going to be in really good shape
man you've done a great job and largely
because a you're paying attention and B
you're making a lot of money it's a big
shovel that helps yeah very nice proud
of you John's in Houston Texas hey John
how are you
good guys how are you better than we
deserve what's up
all right here's what I got going on so
um we have recently sold some Farmland
that we had down in Florida
um made some cash
we currently own the only thing we all
want is a house we owe 287 on the house
um cash on hand right now including
everything in our checking and
everything else is is 282.
um that includes the Farmland proceeds
yes sir okay
so
I have some Employee Stock purchase
stock about 45 Grand worth perfect
um that's an individual stock I work in
Houston so it's oil and gas so it's
pretty volatile
um what are your thoughts on selling
that 45 Grand worth getting out of the
individual stocks
paying off the 287 being completely debt
free houses current valued at about 650
680.
um
the 40 Grand or so as the as the
emergency fund and then we can stack
some cash from there
you just saved me some wind that's
exactly what I was going to say I'd cash
it out pay off the house and that
leftover becomes your emergency fund
anything beyond that you guys can do
what you want with go take a vacation
celebrate I mean Sean you pulled it off
here you got the trifecta you paid off
the house you got your emergency fund
and you saved George wind all in one
answer it was well done sir well done
yeah definitely do all that brother it's
an awesome plan you're right on track
what do you make a year
140. yeah and so now now you get your
baby step seven and just like the last
caller all we got to do now is save more
than 15 into retirement load your
retirement you can load your 401k up you
load Roth IRAs up in good mutual funds
and uh how old are you
39
same age yeah you're going to be a
millionaire by the time you're 45
mathematically
because as the value of the house
increases and you save 25 or 30 000 a
year uh for the next six years and the
growth on all of those things you're
going to be over a million dollar net
worth by the time you're 45 well done
I'm loving this trip you are truly a
baby steps millionaire you know George
there may not be another radio show or a
podcast in America where you can call in
and be succeeding and prospering and
find people happy about it we'll
celebrate with you we are happy that you
are winning we are capitalist pigs we
are glad you are winning most shows are
mad we don't we are we are not angry at
success these guys are success is
amazing we don't think you're a crook we
think you're awesome we think you left
the cave killed something and Drug it
home you're demonstrating work ethic you
are demonstrating character and
perseverance and you are causing these
things to these variables to move you
are not waiting on Washington to fix
your life we love people like you people
when you call in here you will get
celebrated here and if it starts pissing
off the left wing nuts that is just a
bonus you're only fueling Dave guys
that's just a bonus it's just a bonus
man I just love it I'm so I gotta make
it 400k and he's 39 years old that's
just awesome that's a trend I can get
behind forget Bitcoin that's amazing let
me tell you you know what that means I
mean she's helping a lot of people the
people don't give you money if you're
screwing them got to provide value they
they give you money when you're helping
them that's how this works you're
providing value you're adding value to
their life in some way so when you're
doing that you are enhancing Humanity
well done well done this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
State and I want you to have a house but
I don't want a house to have you that's
why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America have you ever
noticed that when you commit to change
in one area of your life it's easier to
make progress in other areas we met
thousands of people on their journey to
Building Wealth who accomplished other
amazing things along the way like losing
50 pounds they find a career that they
love they learn to overcome Stress and
Anxiety what seems impossible becomes
possible when you have a smart plan you
turn up the focus and intensity on your
goals and that's why we're bringing the
smart conference to Dallas Texas on
Saturday October 22nd it is our only
live event of the Fall that is not yet
sold out oh I take that back there's a
few tickets left in Minneapolis for the
Building Wealth but that's it other than
that this is it and you can come live in
person all day total
top of the line number one best-selling
authors and thought leaders in each of
the subjects whether it's um marriage
Craig and Amy groshel will be there and
Pastor Craig will be there from
lifechurch.tv over in Oklahoma City our
friend speaking on marriage Dr John
deloney on mental Wellness Rachel Cruz
can on money Ken Coleman on Career
George Campbell on money there's going
to be a few other surprises I'll be
there we're gonna be talking about
relationships career growth everything
it's all day long you will leave smarter
you need new information and new
inspiration to keep moving it is a giant
pep rally there will be about 8 000 of
us there and there are about 2 000
tickets still left so we can still get
you in uh the VIP and platinum are all
sold out but the general admission is
still available and it's a great great
event Dallas Texas Saturday October 22nd
ramseysolutions.com
slash events for the smart conference
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you miss
measure you pick the wrong color they'll
remake your blinds for free free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code Ramsay to get
the best possible deal today's question
comes from Taylor in Indiana I've come
into some inheritance money and wanted
some ways to invest that is best for me
at 68 years old I have no outstanding
debt and I'm very healthy I've read much
on index funds but need some guidance
thank you
all right so 68 we don't know how much
this inheritance is and we don't know
much about Taylor's financial situation
but I would tell her to make sure she
has all of her debt paid off including
the home and beyond that we can invest
some of this money into mutual funds and
potentially index funds
um so I think that is wise uh as far as
investing goes and she needs to be
working with a pro who can guide her
because this is clearly very new to her
new territory yeah yeah take your time
and learn about it
um shut down with another smart investor
Pros one of the things in order for a
smart investor Pro to be Ramsey trusted
and become a smartvestor pro someone in
the mutual fund in investment advice
business they don't work for us but in
order for us to put our stamp of
approval on them they have to have the
heart of a teacher meaning that their
job is not to sell you something their
job is to teach you
and then you decide to buy it
or not based on what you learn but
George is right I would have you at 68
become debt free before I did any major
investing and again we don't know how
much inheritance you got how much debt
you've got the other pieces of this and
he's exactly right now an index fund is
typically referring to an S P 500 Index
Fund s p is a company called standard
and poor and they rate the top 500
companies on the New York Stock Exchange
called the Big Board okay so they rate
the top these are the largest 500
companies that are that stock is sold
publicly traded on the stock exchange in
an index fund mimics if you were to buy
each of those stocks and you bought 500
shares one share of each or five million
shares and it was an even distribution
across the top 500 companies so if you
take the top 500 companies on the stock
market
and a a measure of all of them as a
group goes up or goes down you are
really measuring the stock market it is
a much much more accurate measure of
what the stock market is doing than what
the than the Dow Jones Industrial
Average there's much fewer companies
yeah which is just a handful of
companies okay so uh it's kind of the
Bellwether because it made back in the
Industrial Age it made the grade for the
media to pick up on it but the
statistical mathematical measure of the
stock market is really the S P 500 so if
you buy an S P 500 Index Fund your money
will do exactly what the stock market
does
not any better not any worse
and so that's how we measure against if
you're going to outperform the market
with another mutual fund then that would
be a fund that makes that has a better
historical track record than the S P 500
does and those are actively managed
someone is actually choosing which
companies they think will beat the S P
500 exactly that's a good point so it's
not a mix that's exactly the same thus
it's a mix that is superior to the the
average and they can be weighted
differently exactly you can put it
however you want so and it's all kinds
of different funds out there that do
that but it but an index fund is
um is a very safe play when you're
playing for a long haul that's not a
safe play to do anything in the stock
market when you're doing it for six
months or doing it for one year which
we've seen with the market the last six
months yeah I mean it's down 15 right
now and so you know it's not it's not a
safe play you would have lost you put a
hundred thousand dollars you would have
lost 15 grand you know you didn't lose
all your money me I didn't lose all my
money but you did lose fifteen thousand
dollars out of your hundred in the last
since the first of the year and it hurts
to see the balance go down ever when
you're investing yeah yeah so I mean
that's but but that's what the s p is
and what it has done and so what you're
buying is a very boring
mutual fund and there's nothing wrong
with boring we like boring when it comes
to investing yeah exciting is uh is
often stupid so we're not trying to be
exciting here we're not we're not trying
to win any sex appeal contests here
we're just trying to get the tortoise to
beat the hair the tortoise is ugly he's
slow and he's steady that feels like a
personal attack Dave but I'll take it
why are you a hair you call me ugly slow
and steady oh cause you're a tourist yep
I'm the tortoise okay well there you go
and uh let it be known Dave has not won
any sex appeal contests
wow you heard it here first on the
Ramsay show wow sorry this is a family
show Dave I apologize this is George
this just got personal but this is a
good point to make for Taylor the goal
let's go back to let me backtrack
quickly let me change the subject to The
Inheritance my goal is to be a steward
of what was given to me right this was a
gift this is an amazing blessing and so
this is how we see money through the
filter of God has given this money for
us to manage and we want to be good
stewards and not have this money
disappear and so I want to try to grow
this money and maintain it and allow me
to have an incredible retirement which
hopefully she's doing at 68 we don't
know her situation but that would be my
goal if you get a million let's have
that balance remain at a million and we
invest this wisely in order to do that
there you go folks that's how it works
George Campbell here to help us with so
many things you never know yeah he's um
he's he's a helpful lad thank you if
nothing else at least I will be helpful
but that's what we do here on the show
Dave uh I'm I'm just I'm I'm
flabbergasted at you Jennifer is in New
York City hi Jennifer how are you
I'm doing great how are you guys better
than we deserve what's up
all right so I know financing anything
is a big No-No but correctamundo
okay
um this in my opinion and my husband's
we're tossing
um we have the opportunity to finance
solar panels versus paying the electric
company you have the opportunity that's
that's amazing I'm glad you I'm glad
they gave you this opportunity oh my God
because not everyone can get this
opportunity
okay so why do you want to do it the
opportunity is our bill will be
significantly lower with the financing
of the pain of the panels versus our
monthly electric bill how much are the
panels
um the payments come out to 330. how
much total poor people ask how much a
month
right now with the new roof it comes out
to 97 000. so you're going to spend a
hundred grand to save a few chunks of
change on your electric bill that's
going to take a long time to Roi
we figured but the way we pay off our
bills will have it done within five
years and then there's no more electric
bill now anything solar panels are a
good investment if you pay cash for them
only not Finance them and they're a good
investment if you can run a break-even
analysis short of about three years five
years is too long to break even on them
because here's the problem you get ready
to market the house you're now having
ninety seven thousand dollar extra
mortgage on the house that did not
increase the value that did not increase
the value of the house that's exactly
right so you're going to get yourself
stuck do not Finance these things no no
no no no no no no bad play
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America George
Campbell is my co-host today this is the
Ramsay show Christian is with us he is
in Fort Worth Texas hi Christian how are
you
I'm good Dave how are you doing better
than we deserve sir how can we help
so uh I am a currently a police officer
I've been for about seven years now and
uh I've been looking to change careers
into the aviation industry uh get to the
airlines but I'm having some
some questions as far as finances go
um you know getting into the aviation
industry is not cheap uh it's kind of a
club that you have to pay your dues to
get into yep and
um and so my question is I know loans
are obviously you're a big No-No but
um I'm kind of looking at it as I'm
investing in myself rather investing in
in some some other thing that I don't
have control over
so my question would be
um should I get a loan to cover uh
flight my flight expenses
to get to the airlines quicker or do you
recommend that I save up for maybe a
year or more and take more time and then
just cash flow it as I go
you're going to regret it if you don't
cash flow it
okay because here's the thing we
discovered
100 of the time none of our plans
execute exactly the way we think they're
going to
right nothing works out perfect I mean
you're a police officer you see people
with have bad plans all the time
you actually have a good plan but none
of our plans work exactly like we think
they're going to I mean little short
plans can you can say I'm going to get
the car I'm gonna drive to work and that
plan works out I get to work you know we
don't even think anything about it no
big deal that plan worked out but when
you're talking about something this
expensive this extensive
um the world of
the airline world the world of being a
pilot whether it's a corporate pilot or
whether it's working for a commercial
airline is changing every day right now
right I mean years ago you could come
out of the Air Force and roll into a
cockpit and you know make 200 000 which
in today's dollars would be a million
you know and those days have been long
gone for a long long time uh and now the
airlines have all kinds of mismanagement
not all of them I mean Southwest is well
run but uh the vast majority of them are
poorly operated every little bump in the
gas prices puts them into a tail spin no
pun intended
um they uh I mean it's just it's a it's
a weird world and by the time you get
there it will have changed it's not it's
not going to be what you think it is and
I don't want you to have
you know a hundred thousand dollars in
debt and you're walking up and now you
feel like you've got to take some
horrible Pilot's job just to be a pilot
and just to get to pay you don't pay on
these debts and you've boxed yourself
into a corner I would much rather you
have the freedom to do this at a at the
speed of wisdom meaning your career
change and the way you do that is you
don't go in debt for this but um
but the here's the thing I I'm guessing
you've had a lesson or two
yeah so I already have my uh my private
pilot's license yeah and so so you've
already you've already been infected
yes and that's the thing is I've already
yeah I've already it is it is a disease
I mean it's a you you can't it is so
freaking fun
oh yeah yeah I fell in love with it too
exhilarating and I have never met a
pilot that hated being a pilot
now some of that they hate some of this
crap they have to do sometimes but the
takeoffs landing and flying they love it
a hundred I mean it's very unusual to
run against somebody goes you know I
really hate doing this it just bothers
me everybody it's like it's like a
disease and so you the problem is when
you you got it's it's an addiction and
you got to be careful man you're gonna
make bad decisions in your in Your
Enthusiasm using the filter of wisdom I
just go all right that's off the table
we're gonna do this how long is it gonna
take how do we speed it up how can I
speed it up how much how much overtime
can I take doing something I don't like
so I get to get my hours so I can move
up you know and go from a a single
engine to a you know get a jet license
and move on and move and then get the
hours and get the hours and get the
hours and keep moving along and then
that puts you in a position to choose
your gig you know
like I mean I've got a good friend that
uh is a corporate pilot and meaning he
flies for a guy that has a big Jet and
he makes a couple he makes a quarter
million a year you know it's not bad and
he he's not putting up with Airline crap
he's not doing he's just flying his
buddy up there to Montana you know I
mean that's all that kind of life right
and it's a good life so but but to get
to that stage you've got as he said
you've got Christians right he's got
some expense and he's got to get his
hours and that kind of stuff but it's it
the it's different than
I want to be an architect and I once
drew a plan and it was fun no no no no
no this is addicting you just I gotta
get back out there people people that
want to become Pilots It's Not Unusual
for those of you that are in that
category to go do really stupid stuff in
pursuit of your addiction all in the
name of Aviation yeah so don't don't do
it just take your time be wise it's a
career it's what we're gonna do for a
living and no you don't need to have a
bunch of data you don't have a dime of
that around it you can do it you can you
can work through the hours and as you
said cash flow if it delays it a little
but that also sets you up for
taking the right job because you're not
some broke guy not desperate you know
what that that's trying to
squeeze your way into Aviation
because I mean if you get on some of
these little um
uh the guys and gals flying some some of
the uh Regional
prop commercials
um I really that's when I know I'm old
when the pilot looks like I've got socks
older than them it's scarce you know I
mean they're they're just straight out
he just started to grow some chin hair
that's just Green Man and I'm sure
they're competent Pilots or they
wouldn't put them in there I mean I'm
not I'm not just not questioning their
skills but uh for an old turkey like me
it's just like oh my God he looks like
he's 12. you know I think he's playing
video games so it's not too much of a
stretch at this point yeah George that
was not comforting at all Nick is with
us Nick is in Atlanta hi Nick what's up
hey guys thanks for having me sure how
can we help
uh so my I'm 29 my wife's 27 and as of
last week we became both consumer deaf
Parade yay and uh yep I'm very excited
about it um and also our emergency
fund's fully funded so we're technically
on four or five and six right now uh no
kids yet uh we have our house and for us
uh we are planning to move we have a
house here in Georgia but we're planning
on selling it in the next eight months
or so and then moving up north
Pennsylvania uh so my question is
do you think it's wise to just pause on
investing right now and instead for the
next eight or so months just try to save
as much money as possible to get ready
for the next home purchase
down payment you have equity in the
Georgia home don't you
uh I do I do I just I'm thinking that it
might be a little bit better just to
save in the next eight months instead
I wouldn't know I'd say 15 of my income
towards retirement and anything else you
can save uh above that and you've been
paying more than that anyway on debt so
you're used to living on less so I just
act like it's day I'm gonna start but
I'm gonna go ahead and get your
emergency fund in place and you just
became Consumer Debt free so now you got
to do baby step three and four and now
I'm oh you got the equity coming out of
the house in Georgia you make the move
with that and just roll that right into
the next house as much as you can yeah I
mean that
I I don't because here's the thing I
don't want to get us
any of us in the habit of jumping in and
out of investing we just need to be
steady steady and invest steady and
invest and don't don't look for reasons
to quit investing even if it's temporary
because you get you get you say okay now
we're going to buy bass boat so we need
to stop investing for six months no no
no no no no no no no no no no well now
we're gonna no no no no no no no no
there's always something and this is a
this is a very it's a valid question but
what I don't want is I just you know
the the people that we've studied that
became millionaires never stopped they
stayed it they stay with them steady
inconsistent and that that's that's that
that time and consistency thing is a big
deal yeah the only time we'd want you to
pause investing if there was a true
storm a true emergency and you know this
move's happening it's eight months away
it's not it's not gonna get the cash you
can do this and you've got you've got
money coming out of the house you're
just trying to Beef It Up A little maybe
move up in house or something as you're
going but I I don't mind you doing all
that but no I wouldn't stop investing
nope wouldn't do it hey thanks for the
call man that puts this hour the Ramsey
Show in the books our thanks to James
Andrew Zach Ben and Austin in the booth
the booth dudes are with us this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we just launched a brand new audience
survey for the Ramsay show and we'd love
your feedback you know to win a 500 Visa
gift card no purchase necessary take the
survey at ramsesolutions.com survey
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the pots
moving in the storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships George
Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Mike is in Baton
Rouge Louisiana hey Mike welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave how are you thanks for having
me on the show sure what's up
good question for you um my wife and I
have been following the baby steps uh we
are Consumer Debt free uh no car loans
um other than only thing we owe is
um on our primary residence and then I
have several rental properties
um that I've got five that still have a
note on them
um we have two senior college kids and
so we've got about one semester left and
we've been cash flow in that
so my question is about the Reynolds um
is it you know I've got a couple of them
that have like a one has a node of
twenty thousand one has a note of uh you
know a little less than forty thousand
is it okay to do the uh that snowball on
those and as I pay those off
you know keep paying those off and then
move to my primary resident
are does it make more sense to sell a
few of those off and just wipe out the
primary residence how many rental
properties do you own total
at gym okay and five of them have a note
and 20 and 40 and what are the kind of
notes
uh one is
like 70 another one is like a little
over 80 and then the last one is uh like
125. okay and your personal residence is
how much owed on it
uh
320 and your household income is what
uh my wife and I make about a little
over 200 a year cool how old are y'all
55 55 yeah yeah that's about right okay
um yeah so two two approaches since your
since your notes on your rentals are
very small compared to your house yeah I
would do those first
because they're easy right right uh if
they were equal I'd pay off your house
first
but they're not equal okay so it doesn't
come up but um
um
and so the debt snowball does work so
there's two approaches you could use to
this and anywhere in between those two
approaches is fine one is simply like
you said just that snowball them and
then pay off your house as quick as you
can after that with all the increased
cash flow you got all the cash flow from
10 rentals plus you got the household
income of 200 so you knock out the 300
in what couple of years probably uh
maybe maybe three years something like
that so uh you know by the time you're
60 you need to be done with all this
right that's what I'm saying okay now if
however you wanted to go crazy and just
be done now you probably could sell half
these rentals and clear and clear
everything couldn't you
yeah yeah I have about 700 000 in equity
yeah so that's the other side
of the spectrum one spectrum is the slow
way plot out over five years one's the
instant way now
and you could do anything in between
which is probably what I would do is
something in between because generally
speaking when I meet people that have 10
rental properties they have two of them
they really don't like that much
right and that's the two I'm gonna sell
and so now now I now I'm not going to
get rid of all of it right now today but
I'm going to accelerate this five year
to maybe a three year by picking off two
or three that I'm not that thrilled with
anyway I might not buy them again if I
didn't already own them kind of property
and just clear those notes and those and
throw those equities at the other
rentals and or at the house and so none
of this is required anywhere in there is
okay
all at once today by selling enough of
it to just clear everything and you know
you've got three cleared properties in
your cleared house and boom we're done
okay that's today the other way is five
years you slow walk it out and then
somewhere in between a hybrid which is
getting rid of something you probably
don't even like anyway that you don't
you know five years from now you you
know that the house is not it's not done
that good it's a pain in the butt it's
always you know it's a older property
it's hard to maintain it's a
neighborhood that's not doing that great
the type of renters I get in there
aren't that great whatever it is
something that that's the way I would
find a property I didn't like in my
portfolio I'd be going this one is less
fun than the other ones you know
what's your long-term plan Mike uh do
you want to retire in a few years have
you talked to your wife about this
I'd like to retire tomorrow
um but no we're probably looking at uh
my wife's a travel nurse and and I'm in
sales so we're probably looking anywhere
between you know probably 10 years from
now
okay this just helps me drive the
decision to go okay if she wants to stop
working tomorrow I might be selling some
of these properties versus using our
future income to try to pay them off
more slowly so I would have a
conversation with your wife about this
make that decision together but I like
the plan of splitting the difference and
if it's not enough we go all right we're
going to sell the next least favorite
one to speed this up yeah and just you
know I'm probably going to pick off two
or three of these that I'm not that
excited about anyway and accelerate this
and make it a three year or three and a
half year plan or whatever but it's a
five-year plan if you don't sell
anything it's what the math is telling
me just I'm just doing quick numbers in
my head but I think I'm pretty close on
that hey that's well done sir you've
done great building this up I'm proud of
you good good work a lot of stuff you
can do there a lot of stuff you can do
Mike is with us in St Paul hey Mike
welcome to the Ramsey Show
yeah hi Dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
yeah so my question is uh that my wife
and I are looking for some advice on
whether or not
um paying off our current home and
paying for a lot of upgrades to
modernize it or selling it and
purchasing a more modern home
um and starting with a fresh mortgage
What's it gonna cost to update the house
uh it's going to cost about a hundred
thousand to upgrade the house we're
looking at
um citing a master bath finishing a
basement and a kitchen
wow that's a lot you think that will
increase the value by a hundred
um that's that's a tough question
um with today's market kind of changing
so much uh so quickly
um we just know that you know
emotionally and you know it's hard for
us to kind of wrap our heads around that
um you know hiring out contractors
getting bids having our house torn apart
yeah and then also how long that Pro you
know all those projects look like I only
did a minor remodel that's not as
extensive as you're talking about while
I was living in the house one time and I
distinctly remember sitting in a lawn
chair on plywood where they had ripped
the carpet up in my master bedroom
watching television and I told my wife
you might be a redneck if you are in
your master bedroom watching a big
screen on plywood in a lawn chair and so
yeah and so I just that that was the end
of me doing this stuff so if I'm in your
shoes I'm just gonna go buy something I
wasn't fool with it life is too short to
remodel house while you live in it it's
a pain in the butt sawdust in everything
it's hard now light remodels are one
thing but what you're talking about is
very extensive it's almost as extensive
as building a house
and uh I personally wouldn't do that I'd
move out and uh I'd just go buy
something life's I mean there's houses
everywhere that's what I would do this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thanks for joining us America George
Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today when you're worried about
money it's all you can think about
stress affects your marriage your family
your career it affects everything until
one day you look up and you feel like
everything's on fire
well you shouldn't have to live this way
and by the way you don't have to when
you have a plan you will discover peace
in your life that you didn't think was
possible Financial Peace University
you'll learn the same plan that almost
10 million people have on how to budget
how to save and spend wisely how to get
out of debt become wealthy outrageously
generous and the course includes Dr John
deloney and George camel and Rachel Cruz
and me it's the best version of
Financial Peace University we've ever
done and we're offering it at the lowest
price we ever have to make it as easy as
possible to get started so decide today
that you're done letting money stress
rule your life get started with
Financial Peace University by visiting
ramseysolutions.com FPU
ramseysolutions.com FPU George it's
worth noting that while everything else
is going up with inflation the cost for
Financial Peace University is the lowest
it has ever been right now I don't know
how you did it worth noting that's
amazing worth noting I have nothing to
do with it someone over in Financial
Peace University decided lower the price
didn't even ask me it's worth everything
I mean the turnarounds we've seen the
first few months of doing this stuff you
save thousands of dollars pay off
thousands of dollars of debt that you
wouldn't have otherwise if you didn't
follow this plan it's crazy absolutely
works all right Valerie's in San Antonio
hey Valerie how are you
hi I'm good how are you Mr Ramsey better
than I deserve how can we help
um I had
I have a shin about baby stats steps I'm
on baby
babies and after we pay off our credit
cards
um technically our next debt is my
daughter's braces
um we owe about 3 800 on them now
um my question is though should we pay
that all off because my husband is
looking for another job
and we wouldn't be living in the same
city or do I still pay it off and then
move on you know I'm sorry if you move
cities are going to take our braces out
if you pay off
payoff if they would honor that or I'm
not sure how that works
so you're in debt for the entire
treatment plan but you're saying the
treatment plan isn't done and you're
moving in the middle no yes well my
husband is looking for another job
um we're from the north we live in Texas
right now and it's just too hot for us
um so she will have braces they predict
about two years
um I'm assuming we're going to move in
the meantime but I just don't know I
wasn't sure I'm not sure exactly how
this works so
um but it says you're saying you're
gonna have to pay someone to finish the
treatment finish dealing with their
braces in another city right
and you're not gonna have to pay the
orthodontist that put them in
well I'm making a monthly payment right
now I know but I mean if you move if you
move you don't have to pay them
I don't I don't know how that works I
don't either I think I think you got to
pay them
yeah well I don't know because they said
it's for the full treatment so well call
them and I call them and ask them and
tell them you're thinking about moving
and what what do you owe today if you
were to move
okay okay
because our next debt is um our car
which is much more so I wasn't sure yeah
you know how that works you know I'm
guessing that there is I I don't know
what they're doing here uh
um I don't know how it works so yeah you
do want to clear it though you don't
want to have a debt hanging over your
head when you're in another city
um
these braces
okay so you need to find out what the
debt is in the event you move in the
next three months and uh and clear that
and then if you stay then you'll
continue the plan you'd pay the rest of
it off right if you'd move then you've
cleared it and you're good to go right
yes by the way get all that in writing
so there's no confusion later
don't uh it's not that they would rip
you off necessarily orthodontists aren't
known for being scam artists or anything
like that but sometimes there's
confusion and when it's written down it
gets rid of the confusion and there may
be something in that contract for the
treatment plan that says this is what
you owe us regardless of what you do
with your life and so it may be the case
kind of afraid you owe the whole thing
but I don't know how that works Jonathan
is in Denver hey Jonathan welcome to the
Ramsey Show
and the surrounding Georgia it's nice
talking to you guys you too how can we
help
my girlfriend I've been dating for
around eight months now
um I have introduced her to you guys's
plan
um I'm trying to find the best way to
help her
um without being an enabler or any sort
of uh you know back end where she ends
up just relying on me
um she does she doesn't appreciate when
I do like ask her if she would like some
money in the and when you know there's a
couple weeks where she would go down on
me because uh she would um she would uh
end up
just saying that she's broke or like she
just can't find a way out so I'm just
trying to find the best way to help her
without being an enabler
so she's actively asking you for money
regularly
no uh she she never does it's more like
I I to ask her if she would like some
money just because I don't like seeing
her struggle and she's offended by that
um I wouldn't say she's offended she
doesn't take any sort of like offense to
it any offensive stand
um she's very understanding she's very
caring
um okay so what's her problem how much
debt does she have
um I am unsure um she won't disclose
that to me I said we're still dating
it's not like we're married or anything
like that but I do see her as a
potential she I do see as me and her
getting married because uh she's not
until you find out what the Flip's going
on
yeah
um I mean uh she's currently in school
um various times where uh she is a CNA
so she gets put on call at times um I
have you know informed her like hey you
know can't try looking at other
departments in your hospital to see if
you could get you know any extra income
or anything like that but I just feel
like sometimes
um
I'm 24. how old is she
uh she's 24 as well okay
all right
um so here's the thing in your mind this
relationship has progressed further than
it has in hers
um you are you are completely dabbling
in her business and she doesn't want you
to know what it is
correct
you are further along the path than she
is
I do feel like in terms of emotion
um it is mutual but no it's not in terms
of Finance no it's not
because you're willing to tell her
everything about you and about your
money and she's not willing to tell you
what's going on with her money
and that may be coming from shame and
some baggage but we have to unpack this
before this relationship progresses any
further
correct yeah this is a blockade to
um
to you all getting to know each other
better
at a deep level called intimacy okay
and so emotional intimacy and so you
guys getting to know each other and
disclosing and starting to share life is
a precursor to you guys going to an into
an engagement
and so until she's ready to take that
next step you're standing over here
ready to go step she's not ready to go
um and so I guess you've just got to
find out a is this shame or B is she
just not ready to move it forward as
much as you're ready to move forward
there's pot either one's possible
I I do feel it's more in the shame part
um just because there is points where
you know uh she is hard on money and she
still tries to find a way to budget and
make herself nature and you don't have
any idea what's going on
because you don't know how much she has
in debt you don't know how much income
she has you don't know what's going on
all you saw is your girlfriend crying
that's all you know
yeah I mean I do know what she makes um
she has uh disclosed some information in
terms of like what she makes on what
she's trying to do but in terms of like
um her find her debt her student loans
and stuff um I've asked her and she says
it's more like I feel like she's ashamed
well I mean you can't go forward in this
relationship until she's can get past
this it's a blockade and so you got to
just back up and give this some more
time or it's a cup it's a cut bait thing
one of the two I don't know which it is
but it doesn't sound like it's that yet
but um at some point we have to be able
to open up about these things in spite
of shame in spite of Pride whatever it
is this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you for joining us America George
Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Anthony is with us in Colorado Springs
hi Anthony welcome to the Ramsey Show
good afternoon guys thank you for taking
our call sure what's up
Realtors here in Colorado and uh we paid
off
uh our first primary residence which is
now an investment property and now we
just paid off our current primary
residence way to go um we have what's
that sir I said way to go
oh thank you sir appreciate that
um we have no debt
um cars are paid off both of our degrees
are paid off
um my question is is we're considering
an investment our third I guess our
second investment property
um and the rates are really high but we
did get a HELOC and we did get approved
on our primary residence and we wanted
your thoughts on moving forward with the
HELOC we did do some numbers and we're
looking at about 500 a month cash flow
on this particular property
mm-hmm
that's when it's rented
correct yes sir
and you know they're not always rented
yes sir and you know Runners don't
always pay
yes sir
okay so
um I'm pointing out the obvious but what
is interesting is that those of us that
are real estate people you and me
um one of the things that happens when
we get to be real estate people is they
take our risk meter out and they break
it with a hammer and we no longer
perceive risk and we say things like oh
it's going to cash flow 500 in a perfect
freaking world only you know but nobody
says that out loud that the Heat and
errors go out in this 3 500 bucks or
roof leak over here water heater blows
out the the pop-off valve and the half
the basement floods and oh by the way
the runner is going to sue you for that
too and nobody brings this stuff up it's
part of the equation though I don't mind
it I it's part of real estate I own a
bunch of real estate as you probably
know but um yeah the cash flow can be a
a bit overstated when we don't take all
things into consideration so
Anthony
um I mean I don't know how long you guys
have been listening to us but we tell
folks not to borrow money
okay and so uh the way I built my second
real estate portfolio the way I built
the first one is like you're doing and I
went broke and lost it all the way I
built my second one is I paid cash for
it and it was slower
now you have no house payment dude
and you have a rental property with no
debt on it so it's cash flowing like a
bandit in that sense
I mean every bit of money that thing
makes it really makes it and none of it
has to go to the bank
um and and I'm gonna guess and say that
you said both of you in real estate I'm
going to guess and say you guys are
making north of 200 Grand aren't you
what do you make
uh we made uh 400 000 last year yeah
okay I thought you were killing it maybe
not this year maybe things are slowing
down a little but but three to four
hundred okay and um and and what can
happen is is that
you begin to feel bulletproof and you
don't perceive the risk anymore in these
situations so I I'm always going to
teach you what we have found to be true
with the vast majority of millionaires
we've studied and that is be the
tortoise
slow and steady and ugly and he always
wins the race
and I'm going to save up and pay cash
for it I will tell you that a beautiful
thing happens when you get to three or
four properties
pretty quickly uh your pro your rental
income will buy you another house every
year
that's awesome but it takes a little
while and the first two are like pulling
teeth and you're tempted to go do a
HELOC because everything in your real
estate world everything in the world I
grew up in tells you to borrow money
no one in the real estate business runs
around saying be debt free it just
doesn't happen but when I find
Millionaires and I study them that own
real estate almost all of them did it
without debt or got out of the debt as
quickly as they possibly could like you
did the first time
something drove you to get out of debt
yes sir so you're saying even if we have
to wait till like next summer if we're
going to pay cash that's the route to go
that's less than a year away if I'm not
talking 10 years from now yeah you guys
have a great income you could buy this
rental property a year from now do a
little slower with way less risk yeah
just be steady Be steady Be steady Be
steady here's the thing we've done
detailed research 100 of the
foreclosures occur on the home of the
mortgage
when when a pandemic hits when it when
your tenant goes into chapter seven and
it's uh four months before the court
opens that case up and you don't get any
payments during that time you got no
issue or someday it could happen to you
like it did a while to me a while back a
tenant came up and said hey um my wife's
got cancer
and stage four
and we don't know what we're gonna do
we're scared and we just said uh well
let's just take it will you keep us
informed we want to stay up with what's
going on but we were able to give them a
break and not have to charge them for a
while
um you know you get yourself in those
kinds of positions that you can be
generous and compassionate and you can
and you don't get caught by somebody
who's trying to mess you over in another
case where somebody just doesn't want to
pay and you have a pandemic moratorium
on evictions or some kind of crap like
that
um and that you know I've been doing
this like 30 years and it's just there's
something always messing with your real
estate real estate's a wonderful
investment and I love it and I want you
to do it but I want you to pay cash
that's what I would do if I were in your
shoes it's what I have done and now I
own
several hundred million dollars worth of
Real Estate
I mean the building we're sitting in
alone is 100 million dollars so um you
know just as an example but that's you
know it's yeah that's what I want you to
do well you make different decisions
when you can do it with no debt with a
lot of clarity move slowly use wisdom
and not be desperate because you owe the
lender
yeah so I like that plan a steady
Grace
is the word gracefulness
the the movements are
more of a dance
rather than a threshing about
it's not it's not a mosh pit at a a punk
rock the rock show yeah and that's
pretty you know you know basically the
the people that we find that really
build wealth they have this steady move
um
you know almost like it's a martial arts
workout or something or a yoga move or
something like that and uh The Tick-Tock
Real Estate Investors are pretty much a
punk rock mosh pit and you're going to
get about the same different result I
mean there's different things there's
just you're going to get a bloody nose
in the mosh bag that's all I'm saying
there's a flow to it here you know crowd
surfing with undependable people you
know that's all it is so it's
but yeah that's that that's Dr John
deloney's Field I guess I should be
stepping into his area
but yeah your yoga I look like yoga but
yeah but the uh uh that's not the point
but there's there's this
when I find uh
people who have built wealth there's a
there I never thought about it until
just sitting here talking about thinking
about it out loud right now but there is
a there's a graceful movement
to the Cadence they're not rushed to
what you're doing there's no rush
there's a wisdom it's
can be kind
um it's a very strong uh it can be
courageous you know but those movements
have all of that in play and it affects
how well the Investments knew
because there's you don't have to force
everything there's not as much friction
there's not as much there's not enough
pressure right next around it and uh we
take all of that out out when you put
debt on it and the more debt you put on
it the more wild and crazy and more
zeros thrashing about that there is and
all that and it's just um yeah there is
a risk factor when we had grand theft
Grand Graham Stefan in the other day
we're talking about that on his podcast
that we recorded I guess I don't know
has that dropped yet or yeah it's all
out there does it okay ice coffee hour
on his separate Channel and you are on
his channel uh once or twice they were
viewing his portfolio yeah and he came
on here for a little while on this show
yeah a sharp young guy but we were just
talking because he's you know well-known
Big Time YouTuber on the uh real estate
investing stuff we disagree on the
financial well not not violently I mean
we're friends but um
um and he's a sharp young guy but uh but
it was it was a fun discussion but
that's the kind of thing and I I wish
I'd thought of that exam sample even
when I was with him that this there's a
gracefulness
a smooth movement of kindness and and a
peaceful region strength that is
different than when you're leveraged to
your eyeballs you know it just changes
everything
is the Ramsay chef
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
bear with each other and forgive one
another if any of you has a grievance
against someone forgive as the Lord
forgave you
Mark Twain said forgiveness is the
fragrance that the Violet sheds on the
heel that has crushed it true poet look
at that he should be a writer open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host today Tyler is
next in Grand Rapids Michigan hey Tyler
what's up in your world
not much what's up in yours struggling
through brother how can we help
haha
um so I would love to run my uh
situation by and then kind of get your
thought
um so a quick summary would be that I'm
graduating from local University here in
December a degree in finance and I'm
graduating debt free thanks almost
entirely in part to my amazing parent
way to go very good recently in terms of
yesterday I accepted a return offers
coming from my summer internship uh one
of the largest banks in the country way
to go what are in your opinion uh some
of the biggest pitfalls or mistakes that
people in my situation tend to make and
what will be the best way to go about
avoiding them
hmm so you're saying my first adult big
boy job out of college I don't want to
screw this up
well number one the principles that got
you through school debt free I want you
to carry throughout which is wise
planning diligence live on less than you
make don't go out and buy a bunch of
toys and get in a house and do things
when you're not financially ready just
because that's what you're supposed to
do after college because you saw your
friends do it and now they're going dude
you don't have a nice why are you still
driving that beater car you don't have a
house yet dude you have a great job in
finance what are you doing that's what
you're about to be up against in the
adult world that no one tells you is the
amount of pressure and comparisons that
are about to come your way
mm-hmm so if you can battle against that
you are going to be just fine because
you're coming out of this completely
debt-free
yes correct what do you drive
uh 2010 Ford Taurus with about 190 000
miles I love it okay
and what will you be making at the new
gig
uh 70 a year and when does that start
February 27 I graduate December
February
of 27 what'd you say January 27th of
this upcoming okay oh so this coming
February okay correct yeah so I have two
months after graduation okay
uh what I would do is get a a modest
apartment
furnish it modestly
um and
um
and
uh uh pile up cash and get you a better
car your car sucks
I'm looking at uh looking at upgrading
yeah about about maybe about doing
anything as quick as you can say five
ten thousand bucks let's move up in car
okay all right uh I if your car was a
better car I'd have you drive it for a
year or two but this one's just you need
to upgrade this one
um sure do and but you don't need to go
into debt to do it we're going to pay
cash and so first big cash goal is build
your emergency fund the next big cash
goal is save up and buy and move up in
car five ten thousand bucks something
like that
um and then you're just going to start
systematically moving towards uh you
know you're investing and start invest
you know whatever you're going to do
you're going to pay cash for and we're
gonna start saving towards the first
house
um and get your 401k and that kind of
stuff started probably down in the
summer somewhere
not about a year from now all that stuff
will start hitting but it sounds like
you've studied our stuff like you know
it all I know what we teach you I've
been an active listener yeah for the
past two years uh then in high school we
did a curriculum in one of my classes
yeah good it's awesome so the
foundations and personal finance our
high school curriculum set the table for
you that's perfect yeah so you're asking
really
mature wise questions because you know
what does happen Tyler and you've
watched your friends do this maybe is
the first thing people do when they come
out of school is um
they go get a car payment
because they deserve a new car to go
with their new job to go with their new
apartment and they usually rent an
apartment or house that is uh too nice
I did I didn't buy a new car but I did I
mean Sharon I got married like two weeks
after I graduated and we rented a three
bedroom townhouse
and there were two of us it was done I
mean you know it didn't make it's Dumber
To Rock why do we need three bedrooms
but we thought you know and six months
later we moved into a little one bedroom
because we grew up we got smart you know
and uh had an adult or two speak into my
life and go that's stupid and um it was
and and so but that's
uh uh and it was half the the one
bedroom was half the price I mean it
didn't make any sense to make any sense
at all and he can get some roommates too
I mean he's a single guy coming out of
college yeah and but yeah so you're
gonna kind of get stabilized in your
uh you know in your uh lifestyle and
everything and just don't jump in
the problem is people graduate they
start making 70 grand they act like
they're making 700 Grand and they go
bananas and it's like they've been
working four years living on you know uh
cafeteria food
um sitting on old used furniture and
horrible stuff in the dorm or whatever
and now I get to go out and have like a
real life and then they they
dramatically overspend just blank check
that thing Tyler's not gonna do that no
but some of Tyler's friends are and he
may already be observing that but the
biggest mistake most people do is they
go get a car payment day one as soon as
I get out of school they go get a car
and a big car payment and it's a very
nice car that they can't afford so save
up pay cash for a better car you do need
to do that but we're going to pay cash
and and then let's just
cash flow no debt any moves you're going
to make past that and Furniture whatever
it is you're doing and he set up the
foundation I mean it's rare to meet a
kid who's graduating completely debt
free because his parents yeah we're wise
so it sets them up differently than a
kid who's coming out of college with 100
Grand asking us what do I do now because
now we go you got to clean up this mess
for the next three years exactly exactly
so he's got an amazing he's got three
years of your life back that's the power
of following this plan so way to go
Tyler and personally if you're if you're
more normal you've got 10 years of your
life back that you don't have this debt
hanging around you this epic failure of
student loans you know George I was
thinking earlier today it's on that same
subject
the um
our documentary on student loans is
absolutely a must watch right now it's
even more relevant than when we release
it yeah borrowed future uh with all the
discussion of student loans and of
the cost of education and what the cost
of education is going to do as a result
of this forgiveness with the Forgiveness
actually comes through
from the Biden Administration
she had to figure out if it's
does require an act of Congress or not
um this time literally usually you say
that ironic not not as a not as a figure
of speech but an actual act of Congress
um does Congress have to approve the
spending and most people think you do
and so can he get that through before
the the Democrats do not any longer have
a majority after midterms because
they're going to take there's going to
be a bloodbath on that most people say
most people believe so then what do we
do from there and
um so borrowed future
to set you up to have uh the young
people in your life be a Tyler instead
of being hundreds of thousand dollars in
debt it's it's just essential what you
study matters where you study it matters
and uh College choice is really tied
into this whole epic failure called the
Student Loan program and uh we disclose
and uh uncover
reveal the predatory nature of the whole
program and it's it's the underbelly of
this thing's National it is dark stuff
it's nasty and dark and evil and it's
out of control and it was a
well-intentioned idea that got the
federal government's hands on it which
will screw up Christmas
and uh man it is a mess and you know and
it still begs the question that we asked
in the documentary or the statement that
we ask in the documentary that if you're
going to forgive student loans while
you're still making them that is
intellectually dishonest
if they're so bad and so oppressive and
the the
poor people that have been taken
advantage of have that they must be
forgiven
and yet you're still making them
it's just straight up wrong you're
asking politicians to be logical Dave
that's where you messed up well critical
thinking skills should be required
somewhere in the vicinity of Washington
DC but apparently not so well every
parent needs to watch this because it'll
spark some great conversation every
parent everybody that has a teenager
every teacher if you're a teacher we'll
still let your classroom watch it for
free so get in touch with us it's one of
the biggest documentaries on uh you know
on Amazon Prime so go out there and
watch it it's a Google Play it's out
there
borrowed future
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the Ramsey Show and
we'd love your feedback you can be
entered to win a 500 Visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramsesolutions.com survey
foreign
[Music]